all right dan is with us in Dallas Texas
hi Dan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey how you doing be better than I
deserve what's up in your world oh
nothing much I just had a question about
jobs of curly I'm 22 years old working
at an insurance company in Dallas I just
moved here I'm having trouble deciding
between continuing my career here or
going to the police force
Howard bachelors and from Oh justice and
I have like a passion for the
consciousness system but I also don't
want to risk losing a potentially good
job in insurance industry so this ought
to get your opinion on that well I mean
you've gone to a lot of trouble to get a
criminal justice degree you obviously
wanted to go into law enforcement why
wouldn't you do that oh I didn't do as
you said I didn't research my degree or
nothing like that was originally a
nursing and then a general studies and I
can't just landed in chrome injustice in
so you landed it wasn't like a plan that
you said oh I've always would be in law
enforcement yeah okay well then let's
ask it this way you said you're 22 right
yes sir
when you're 42 if you were 42 years old
and you could talk to your 22 year olds
version of you what would you tell you
that you would wanted to do what do you
want to do for the next 20 years of your
life huh I really want to be in real
estate and um why is because my
grandmother didn't real estate and I've
always kind of you know looked up to her
and you know where she's accomplished so
that's common by anvil just eventually
get into real estate because of what she
accomplished yeah so you see her as
successful and you want to be successful
yes but you could be successful at a lot
of different things why real estate oh
nothing you know I think it's like a
secure area
I don't know all right this is the kind
of thinking I want you to do though okay
you've said two things that two words in
our discussion that I want to call out
one is you said good job it's two words
actually and there's no such thing okay
a good job is something where you can
exercise your gifts and you're
passionate about it you get better at it
every year and you make more money every
year and that's a good job and so you
can have a good job teaching you can
have a good job in real estate you can
have a good job in law enforcement you
can have a good job at insurance but the
definition of a good job is what is
God's calling on your life Dan what are
you going to look back when you're 42
and go I'm glad I spent the last 20
years of my life doing that that was a
fun ride you might change directions at
some point in your career but at least
the time that you're in the career
you're doing it you're not just seeking
out security and you're not just seeking
out money and sometimes people call that
a good job and that's not a good job if
you got security and you got money but
you have no joy and no passion and
you're not growing and you're not
getting better and you're not increasing
every year you have a lousy job I don't
care if you're a doctor you got a lousy
job okay the second thing you said was
secure there's no such thing you are
only as secure as your ability to get up
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home you're a go-getter the fact you
called the show and asked the questions
you asked make you a go-getter you're a
person who won't be denied and your
motor is running and so act on that and
that is your security by the way selling
residential real estate is not secure at
all it's very insecure your income is
very volatile it's very up and down
until you get a real book of business
going and you get your pipeline full and
you can make a lot of money you're going
to work a lot of hours you're going to
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
and you're going to learn a lot about
people that'll make your hair curl and
everything else while you're working
residential real estate but it's a fun
business I've been in it and I grew up
in that business my parents were in the
business I got my real estate license
when I turned 18 so not trashing it but
dude it the people that make 200 grand a
year in that world they work their butts
off by the way the people that make two
and a grinnin almost anywhere
work their butts off so what I want you
to do is I want you go back and ask
yourself that question again when I'm 42
what am I going to be glad I did and
it's not collect a paycheck and be
secure that is not that's not the answer
to the equation it's what are you going
to be laying your hands to that give you
joy to where you on Monday morning you
go wow I'm checked I get to get up and
go do this every morning and if that's
in the insurance world that's fine if
it's in the law enforcement world that's
fine it's in the real estate world
that's fine could be in something
completely different from any of that so
that's my challenge for you and then
that will lead you if you'll answer that
question adequately what are you good at
what do you like doing when you do it it
makes you smile it gives you energy it
doesn't drain you it doesn't take energy
um you know I'll give you an example I
do the show for three hours every single
day every day five days a week three
hours answering questions I've done it
for 25 years and I'm still happy when I
walk in here the day I'm not happy the
show's over well I don't mean that day
because everybody has a bad day but I
mean the day I quit being happy for an
extended period of time ago I hate doing
this dadgum show just chained to the
show it's over and Kellie's have a job
she's looking at me funny but now we'll
put one of the other ramsey
personalities butt in here and let them
answer the questions you know but I mean
you got to do something you like doing
and I like doing the show it's part of
the rhythm of my life I enjoy it I enjoy
I'll go to Grand Rapids tomorrow and you
know I'll be gone like 16 17 hours I'll
be exhausted when I get home and but
I'll be on stage for four hours three
hours with Chris Hogan up there I will
have an absolute blasting Grand Rapids
tomorrow speaking to that third sold-out
group it's candy for me do something
like that damn that's what I'm talking
about where you feel that way like I
feel about this show where I feel about
being in Grand Rapids same thing hold on
I'm going to have Kelly give you a copy
of a book you need to read as my gift
it's called start because that's right
where you are sir this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show